It has been 7 years since we founded Rayark back in 2011
and we have released 7 games so far
Some of them are immensely popular among gamers
like “CYTUS”, “DEEMO” and “VOEZ”
All three of which have reached the top spot on Google Play
in over 100 countries and regions
Other games, like casual games “Mandora”
and action-RPG game “Implosion”
were also big successes
Almost every Rayark game has been ranked as No. 1
in the Google Play Store top charts at some point
I think the process of creating a game is
sort of analogous to playing a game
Your heart wants it to be artistic and intuitive
but your brain says you need in-depth business analysis
to create a good game
Launching a successful game to the market for me
means you are able to make money whilst
also being able to satisfy your desire for creativity at the same time
Tools are very important to game development
In fact, good tools can significantly improve
the communication efficiency
In the early days when Cytus II just hit the market
it had a crash rate of 8%
We then used the Android vitals dashboard in the Play Console
to monitor app performance so we could find out about
any problems for particular versions or devices
This data helped us identify and fix the issues quickly
resulting in a reduction of 0.12% to the crash rate
and great improvement to the stability of Cytus II
The Google Play Console has a very nice feature
called staged rollout
With internal tests, our internal QAs can play and
test the latest version every day
Closed test and open test allow us to
run pre-release versions of our app
with targeted users all over the world
We can read feedback from users speaking different languages
directly in Play Console and all feedback is
automatically translated to the language that our developers use
Furthermore, Play Console actually sorts and filters the feedback
by many different dimensions
for example, we can select a cluster to get more details
about a specific issue like app crashes or design problems
This helps us increase our productivity considerably
The Play Console also offers a tool called A/B test
With this feature, we can A/B test changes
to our store listing or icons
and find out which version has a better conversion rate
It has helped us increase the conversion rate of the downloadby 10%
which is 4.8% higher than other similar games
We think this feature is particularly useful to game developers
We see Rayark as more than a game company
but as a content provider
Technology is evolving with time
so are the game platforms
But still, something stays and dwells at the bottom of gamers’ hearts
That is the emotions people experience
when creating or playing a good game
What I mean here is that to create wonderful moments
that people can cherish deeply
Intellectual Property is the focus of what Rayark does today
and will always be committed to in the future